what do you think the secret of the
success of my time is why is it such a
big hit
I think the imagination fact we can go
anywhere and the boys do that they bring
it they can twist every story and it
makes perfect sense and in an
extraordinary way and the magic of the
fairy tales but it's also based you know
everybody tries to play it as real as
they can and are the characters have fun
and heartwarming and dodgy really you
know we get to exactly you get to be
super evil and we did right I was saying
that you because you're asking like we
know how Ursula's like the like the like
darkest you know creatures and I was
like like you're you're really effed up
well sure yeah they gave me no you know
who are you without some of those but
yeah no I did they did decide to turn
make karela as dark and as irredeemable
as possible yeah
why did you ever I loved that because I
didn't have to be nice it was fantastic
so but it was it was a big call because
a lot of the villains do get you know
you've got your happy ending and a lot
of people do get to to show the other
side of them and why because I think
they're they were originally talking
about was evil born or made
yes and yeah exactly and I think rolla
was just born bad to the bone it's very
rare it's very rare to kill villains and
characters in Once Upon a Time and
obviously your death had a huge impact
on the rest of the season what's it like
being more the only ones have been offed
as it works well I can only assume I was
extremely difficult on set I miss Harry
just need to make sure she's really you
never you never know what's gonna happen
episode 2 episode which is kind of
exciting it leaves it sort of wide open
when you're if you're in an episode
where you're not necessarily driving the
story but you're a part of say that the
see the beer at the C storyline and
you'll be doing things new we won't
necessarily know where they're gonna go
or where they're gonna lead and you just
throw yourself in in good faith and
sometimes I mean I would I'd endlessly
build it be building my part adding in
things that I was convinced that mr.
gold was her true love and I
I would be camping it up horribly I
can't be with anybody anybody I just
decided warm for everyone's for
everybody call them the puddin ended on
the paper cliffhanger is that any talks
are you coming back next season who
knows I said nobody guys no that's true
that's true you you know you're only
your own e is dead or as happy as the
creator's decide you're going to be you
get the call yeah exactly because Selena
came back didn't she came back yeah I
wanted them in the episode after I died
the author and and gold were at my very
poorly attended funeral and I kept
saying I was texting Patrick who plays
the author could just rip open the
coffin and see there's just a wig and
just have like black and white fur
disappearing and in the background so
ever on for next season technically
speaking you could come back yeah we
couldn't be teaching her some movements
tell ya
we've got some moves to show her kind of
in the year and superheroes if you could
play any superhero just I mean twirl I I
would maybe do Batman
oh I like that I like the gadgets I'd be
a black man yeah exploitation movie
coffee yeah is there coffee with the big
afro oh yeah forget Christie love was
this old tiny tiny old like six-episode
70s show called get Christie lovin it
was like awfully awful but it's
fantastic
awful in a great way awful in a great
way I want to be yeah yeah but she's
more of a coach she's not a superhero no
no yeah there you go you could
reorganize that black man and Wonder
Woman you mean like that yeah
you